علا أردني - دين هو المؤسس المشارك
لشركة bit oasis ،
وهي واحدة من أولى عمليات تبادل العملات المشفرة في المنطقة ،
وكان فادي
أحد أكبر المرشدين لدي ، نعم أنا هنا
لأحمل كلمة التعب و / أو
أسس أكبر شركة لوجستية في
الشرق  إيست إيجينغ ماكس في عام 1982 يكرس الآن
كل وقته لدعم
مشهد الشركات الناشئة المتنامي في المنطقة ،
وقررت أن الرئيس التنفيذي للشركة
لن يكون وظيفتي الدائمة ، حيث
يمكن لمؤسس الخروج فعليًا من عمله ، فقد قررت
أن أكون مستثمرًا ملاكًا  رأس
مال استثماري وهذه هي المرحلة المبكرة
لدعم الشركات التي كانت قد
بدأت لتوها في النهوض بصندوق رأس المال
الاستثماري الخاص به ، كان Wanda أول من استثمر في
bit oasis منذ ذلك الحين ، واصل
توجيه
Ola وآلاف آخرين في
رحلاتهم الناشئة وهكذا  الشركات الناشئة مثل
البشر ، لقد بدأوا وهم
أطفال ويجب على شخص ما أن
يعتني بهم للاستثمار فيهم
لرعايتهم لمساعدتهم على دعمهم
وقد اخترنا أن نكون في ذلك
مرحلة مبكرة جدًا لأن هذا هو المكان الذي نحن في
أمس الحاجة إليه ، حيث تقوم ببناء
المستثمرين الملائكة الذين يشتبهون في البيئة الاقتصادية ، فإن المستثمرين الملائكيين في المرحلة المبكرة
هم الأشخاص
الذين يبنون العمود الفقري للنظام البيئي
في المنطقة بدونهم ، فإن كريمات
هذا العالم لن يكون مصدر هذا العالم
موجودة